oc3 viewers we like surprises and AUB
sauce pref conference there was a big
surprise delivered by this man Jason
Vanderburgh the creative director on for
honor yeah for honor you surprise
surprise hey what's up I got a video
game you got a video game we've been
working on it you guys like just one
play shop the crap out of people blam
yeah that's what I love the debut
trailer and then like oh yeah here are
the guys out here the girls coming I was
last audience all like oh my god that's
good cuz you want it to be more tangible
you know after sort of stories about to
see you see games announced and then not
you don't see him for a while yeah you
really get that it's stealing your teeth
well with [ __ ] that's a bad option
stila dirty wrong aren't get it
dangerous you don't want to go onto the
battlefield like that no new well but
this game we got a new way to fight
right so we have this new controller and
this new way to put the sword in your
hand and so we're like you kind of have
to show it to you because I could say
hey I got a new way to fight uh trust me
wouldn't you trust this face exactly why
I'm there right so it's that we were
like got new weight of new it if i watch
can play it we're live on the floor we
got 16 pods back at the booth we got
people cycling through there having a
good job to do here man you don't want
me to leave you hanging on stage let's
talk about for honor a little bit I want
to talk about that new way to fight in a
sec I want to get into it but first
let's set the stage ah we're in the
medieval era ish ish well it's certainly
a place where they add swords yeah it's
this is sort of inspired by it's not a
history game though yeah this is of
course I mean we got nights Vikings in
samurai he's gonna see in our trailer
here right I don't know if you know this
ok Vikings and samurai did not actually
fight a lot of over on a European
battlefield in history that didn't
actually occur but what they're good
should have it should have and that's
why we're here along comes you guys to
make that right make that happen so I
you know what we've seen is basically
this is sort of a sort of pure sword
fight kombat thing but they're big big
battles it's not just one-on-one it's
you've got you've got your teams but
then there's player characters and non
player characters every day I on the map
we got this thing on the front line we
got this big group of guys old soldiers
that are battling over that central Lane
you can get
in there and are ya with the swing and
you're sort of you do you sort of cut
you're cut your swath through the eye
but once you cuz everybody wants to cut
a swath every yeah if you're all in the
battlefield you want to cut a swath but
you also want someone to test your
mettle and that's a boy just hack your
way through it and that's what those
other players are gonna do for you game
is for before so you got four other guys
on the other team who are coming after
you hunting you down ready to lock it
lock in and do a duel alright so once
you lock in your sort of squaring off uh
how does that how does that control
scheme orc just give us a little quick
over quick okay so you want to go fight
you're driving around third person game
you're driving around with the left
stick yeah first I'm gonna lock with a
trigger left trigger left trigger I'm
gonna now we're in guard mode so I've
got my disengaged daddy gonna let go and
exactly you want to go fight in that
lane you're gonna fight him that that
front line there you're gonna be swing
in without lock but if you see another
player you want to fight you're gonna
walk on yeah you gotta focus exactly
we're gonna do cuz this guy's serious
right okay so let's fight now I got my
guard out and when I lock now my right
stick becomes my sword gonna becomes my
guard I mean three guards left right in
top okay so what happens is I move my
right stick I'm moving my sword to the
left to the right to the top yeah
wherever I'm holding my sword that's
where I'm guarding yeah if you attacked
me where I'm guarding bang I'm gonna
bounce right off right now if i push the
attack button right which you got two
attacks on the bunt on the shoulders
there okay I got a quick and a heavy and
on the two triggers um I'm gonna I'm
gonna attack on the side I'm holding my
weapon so if I'm over here on the left
I'm gonna pull the [ __ ] attack button
I'm gonna attack you on your right side
yep I'm on the top of an attack you talk
over so you can see from where I'm
holding my weapon what I'm probably
going to do and what this does is just
creates this cycle where you're looking
at my stance I'm looking at your stance
we're both like this is where I'm safe
this is where i'm safe but i gotta move
my weapon to attack you yep you gotta do
that i gotta open myself up for a second
do some faint smith painting who are you
into it what are you and this is and
this now we're fighting now we're having
the emotions of gameplay this whole
system that we've created here it's
called the art of battle uh-huh this is
our core new thing right called the art
of battle you put that on a four before
setting where I also got to worry about
one of your guys coming up behind me
attend ganky honig a gag
ah see that's or dishonor once or twice
man I'm a night I fight honorably no uh
honor in battle knows only they live and
dead what are you a Viking good maybe oh
man get down with some Vikings all right
dead so we got that so that's that style
the system works that's good that's yeah
sort of helped me wrap my head around
just sort of the basic sort of flow
there and you can see how that when
you're engaged with another human player
gets immediately complex as you're
trying to figure each other out just
like each other out yeah uh so what is
you know what happens so you smite your
opponent haha so smitten you I roar to
the heavens like a blood offering does
and what how does the game progress what
are you sort of earning for that how
does that affect the flow of battle
right on well first you killed one of
your opponent's so now they're down to
three people live and they need to go
back and respawn right so they're
they're dead for a while uh-huh but also
you're getting you're getting score off
of that and III we're playing this mode
called Dominion which is kind of a
modified it's our sort of twisted
version of domination sort of classic
nomination got three capture points and
you're shooting for a thousand points
right you're getting points by killing
peel and other players killing the
soldiers in the field but you're also
getting temporary points when you take
the capture point so you hold one of
those capture points uh-huh you're gonna
get a big score boost like 250 points
right but that's those are points it can
be taken away oh really yeah because of
course the enemy team could take the
floor you just have to hold you're gonna
hold that end up thanks to 15 years I
but if it goes if they yank it it was
going right first first team to a
thousand points great pushes the enemy
team into breaking now the enemy's
starting to break they're getting ready
to they're getting ready to route right
what you'd have to do then they can't
respond oh ok I'm come down now it's
hunt them down kill everyone to the
enemy team and you win the game what is
yeah what's the recourse though that's
breaking take a capture point you take
one of those capture points back you're
gonna take 250 points away from the
enemy team and you're back in the game
and you can respawn again exactly you
respawn your whole team over is dead
they come right back and now you're
rolling again alright so there's a lot
of this tug-of-war at the end that's
pretty cool now tell me how I archers
and siege weapons factor in here are
those sort of tides you capture points
how does that so play and so you saw in
the on stage demo you saw a lot of like
the arrows coming
shut up the catapult explosions in the
background those are what we call feats
those are player abilities oh really yes
those are those are those and their
slots you got four of them eat for each
for each hero right Ichiro has four
slots and what you're doing when you're
when I'm fighting people i'm sort of
earning my way up I'm sort of earning my
battlefield crittle feel credibility
yeah and if I get that that fourth one
up there I can go I want a catapult
strike right there and it's the
countable guys are like yes sir has been
kicking ass we are all right what do we
got this exactly exactly all right so
and then each each type of hero has
their own sort of kit of feats to pick
from and you can customize their load
outs um how you want to go and now we've
got Vikings we've got samurai we've got
nice and so we said that last one though
I'm like man come on night night yeah i
think the demo is demonstrated on more
Viking sensibility really I'm really
shocked at this point I'm surprised by
that and it's not just the factions
we're playing it's also the maps you're
playing instead Elegua blue oh it is
every map a castle kind of situation as
it does it have multiple areas give us
an idea of the size and setting and the
variety of maps so we're not really to
where we brought our first map here and
we're not really ready to talk about the
whole scope of the world yet all right
we're gonna go into some solo campaign
stuff and we're gonna start talking
about that in the future right but one
way to think about what we're gonna do
with this space right it was um if you
think about this game is kind of a
shooter with swords yeah right that's
the way we're going to approach the map
cycle right we're gonna need a bunch of
variety everything's gonna have its own
theme right we need a bunch of those to
sort of evoke this world because those
maps are gonna be how you how you really
get to feel the history of the space
right absolutely so you're gonna be
hearing a lot more from us about all
that in the months to come and how about
anything about a campaign or they're
sort of different factions have their
different stories to play out so we're
good I can confirm we're gonna have a
full solo campaign I'll be able to play
that it's going to be a on its own a
reason to play at least enjoy the game
right it's going to be a full experience
we're not ready to talk to you guys
about what's going to be that will be
down the road we've got lots of ways to
play we already have in the the the
build today we've got bots
that work for you so if you want to play
multi if you like the multiplayer modes
you want to just play those in train I
just play those matches against bots
right you're also going to be play below
play co-op of course and super required
because this is a game about fighting
with weapons split screen absolutely key
feature for us Oh split screen that
really bring in bringing conflict into
the living room well you want to sit on
the couch and beat up your buddy right i
mean that's kind of the thing that is
equipped with its ok you know i am sure
you could go operate or or you could win
I don't know Jason for honor an exciting
debut for Ubisoft and you guys here and
from 3 2015 do you have sort of a
release window or anything in mind we
really don't you're something sure out
there in the future but what I can tell
you is you're gonna start hearing from
us about live periods we're here at the
show to kind of introduce new mechanics
show you guys what we're doing make sure
it works like good to be back you know
that good stuff organ stop I mean you
know it's a game that has this kind of
roots and multiplayer of course we're
gonna be talking to you guys about life
periods and down the road so we're we're
out here as early as we possibly can
because that's gonna be a really key
part of making sure that that final
product kicks ass well we're glad you
came out Jason it was a pleasure to talk
to you pleasure to see for honor in
action thank you very much great to be
here absolutely alright even though you
are a Viking I'm about that what a urine
that your night guy do we even clarify
this I know right i I'm not on the
inside okay all right okay i get i well
we'll meet will meet sometimes it feels
y'all this without stick maybe not today
maybe not tomorrow but someday
Vanderburgh get you all right coming up
next folks it's a look at tom clancy's
the division another game that made a
splash at ubisoft press conference don't
go away